i'm pretty much a stay-at-home mom i
think i
sacrificed some stuff to be a
stay-at-home mom but i think it's
absolutely worth it
i think i heard an interview before from
a hospice nurse
and she said what is people's biggest
regret on their death beds
and they say i didn't spend enough time
with my family
she said she'd always heard it from men
but in recent years she's heard it more
for women
who chose to have a career
and you know send their kids off to
daycare and i understand some people
have to do that
some people do not have the financial
means i understand that i am
privileged in that sense however if i
have the option to be a stay-at-home mom
and be there with my kids then i will
take that
so i think that i i it's worth it i
think just
that i have influence over my child and
it isn't just a stranger who's raising
them whose
ideology i may not agree with and who
may be
out of his life and i'm always going to
be there
i was going to ask are you going to send
him to public school that's a decision
we have not made
yet okay um but he's he's only three
mm-hmm i am homeschooling him i suppose
even though yeah he's learning his
colors and numbers and the dinosaurs
he knows quite a few of them have you
given him any
skateboards should give him a skateboard
he actually has a
scooter all right i guess he has like a
dinosaur helmet with spikes on nice
oh i like that that's punk yeah yeah it
was it was crazy
uh you know growing up skateboarding
there would always be these scooter kids
at the skate park and skateboarders were
so annoyed because they'd get in the way
and
didn't know what they were doing but
i'll tell you the craziest thing is like
i see this scooter kid at the skate park
and i'm like oh these scooter kids man
like they're always in the way i get it
they're kids they're here they're
playing it's fine but their parents got
to tell them about like teaching about
etiquette and stuff
then it's like four years later and the
scooter kid is now like 15 and he's
doing backflips and like
launching you know 10 feet in the air
and i'm like damn
the scooter kid's good now this is rad
like now it's fun to watch
so yeah scooter's cool no i think
definitely physical activity mental
activity
and i'd say dude if it were me don't put
them in school man
it's tough that having having having
your kid
understand the system from within it is
probably really important
but it can only be done with your
guidance outside of the school
absolutely like for me i went to grade
school and they you know they fill your
head with complete bunk garbage
and then i would go home and have my mom
be like that's not true it set you
straight yeah and then i was like oh
and then i realized like i realized what
the system was and
sort of i was very young but i was like
oh okay so this is not entirely
legitimate
and so i would see how the system worked
but was constantly being reminded from
outside of it what the system was
also i started working for my family's
business when i was like 9 or 10 years
old because we had a family
we had a family cafe and then you hear
real conversations from real adults you
deal with real money and you have real
experience in the real world
you go to school and everything's so
trivial and nonsensical you know
yeah i think parental involvement is
number one i grew up going to government
schools
but i had a family who's more
conservative my grandfather
was a huge influence on me he was more
of a libertarian type and
he would tell me you know just kiss
their butt get an a
and then just everything they say go out
the other ear that's good that's good
yeah it is a lot like military
academy like public school sit down wait
for the bell to ring raise your hand
don't speak out of line
you know stand up uh address some places
have dress codes
i wonder if sending kids off to military
school at the age of four or five is
wise
i don't know about military school
pre-military school let's call it like
pre-k
no i think having uh uh the parents
a good balance between between masculine
feminine and physical activity and
and mental activity having uh a strong
father and mother
who can provide a good balance of you
know perspective
suppose not everybody gets that though
you got to be lucky are you going to
have a dad who's like a short overweight
middle manager who
is deferential to everybody and just
whenever someone pushes him around he
apologizes and tells his kid to keep his
head down and not fight back
or is he gonna be this like ripped
lumberjack guy who's like don't take
nothing from nobody
and then he like here's your shotgun i
know you're seven but i think you can
handle a 12-gauge son
and then you gotta have the mom being
like don't give him a 12 gauge when he's
seven you gotta have that mix you know
what i mean
yeah you got to give him the 410. come
on man start small
give a kid a gun that big geez no i
don't know i think
you know it's tough especially now
because
millennials aren't having kids they lack
purpose
and there seems to be a in my opinion
dangerous cultural shift that has
nothing to do with tradition or
progression
you know uh it's not about being
progressive or being a traditionalist
it's about
i mean humans have kids you know what i
mean that's our purpose yeah
i mean it's it's i don't know if it's
purpose but um
i know like when you have kids your kids
become your purpose
and that if you don't have kids humanity
ceases to exist
your culture ceases to exist here's
what's fascinating to me
when i hear from liberals and their
attitude is very much
who cares if america ceases to exist
have you ever heard the sentiment from
these from liberals like you've seen
them on you sit on twitter
they'll they'll take like a a quote from
a conservative who's like you have to
have kids to preserve america and its
culture
and they'll be like why
and that's why it's really fascinating
to see conservatives
this overlaps a lot with like
immigration yeah concern about
immigrants coming in and displacing
american american culture and getting
rid of christmas
conservatives very much want to preserve
you know conserve
these traditions and their culture i'm
actually
not particularly conservative i just
think if you don't have kids then
there's no people
so i mean i guess we can build robots to
replace ourselves we're not doing that
either
or live longer we live to be 200 then we
don't
we need to have like 40 as many children
or something
maybe it's like what you were saying ian
was it apoptosis yeah
that's for real man it's like the the
mice the mouse utopia
you get to a certain point where you're
just consuming and doing nothing and
just
before the roman empire crumbled
basically a lot of homosexuality started
or homosexuality spiked i believe and
there was just a lot less
making babies i don't know they were
living in like the age of gluttony
pretty much
they had everything they didn't care
they didn't want to serve in the
military anymore because
that they might lose what they had and
they they loved their things
and um then they got conquered from from
the outside
yeah yeah i think you know people
mention a lot the the mouse utopia
have you heard of that they basically
created the space where they put a bunch
of mice or rats or something and they
gave them all food and
said like no matter what happened they
never ran out of food they never they
never ran out of food or water
and so they eventually just like some
stopped eating
some started eating others some just
stopped reproducing and just died
and you know people wonder if we as
humans are susceptible to something
similar where
we've reached this point where people
don't have to work
and i mean it when you've got somebody
who lives in new york city and their job
is to write articles for buzzfeed
i'm sorry that's not work it's not work
work is like i have to grow the food i
have to hunt i have to build the house i
have to start the fire
i have to generate the electricity to
power the machines i have to find the
energy source
so that we can stay warm in the winter
writing articles about celebrity gossip
is not work
oh they'll say it's so isn't that a good
thing though like i look
back i'm a woman obviously but my great
grandfathers were coal miners and
so much hard work i
i look back at my my great-grandmother's
like they had to cook everything from
scratch and wash everything from
you know they have laundry machines or
dishwashers and
i just i think we're so lucky to not
have to do all that stuff
going going back to yes and so i'll
attach you down to what ian was saying
about we talked about rome right
yeah or greece well the roman both
probably yeah i think there's a lot of
vanity and and gluttony at the end of
both of those here's what i see
when the the culture
is stagnant you know uh or
if the technology isn't fast enough and
if
you know it's a weird hybrid moment of
reaching that apex of technology with
population
to where the culture stagnates then once
rome collapsed the technology persisted
a lot of this information persisted and
spread out a little bit and then started
to improve
and people started to fight again and
work hard again and then you get you you
know you come to
the colonial era european uh colonialism
and things like that
striving for more and no longer just
being like i want to be a lay about
glutton because i have all the stuff
so the technology remains things become
easier but then the quest
reemerges so maybe what's going to
happen for us is that some kind of
you know mass massive you know
century turning or millennial turning
millennium
turning where we've reached this point
where we as a culture
are all gluttonous because technology
has granted us this
after our culture collapses then there
will be a struggle again
but that technology will still exist so
then in another couple
hundred years it'll be even better for
everybody
and then they'll start becoming
gluttonous and lazy you know what i mean
i guess the question is do we have it
too good
in america because my my father-in-law
is from the soviet union
and he you know it wasn't such a great
time in the soviet union he's like looks
at these american kids and teenagers and
millennials having this
depression and anxiety and he's like
what the heck
you guys have pretty much everything you
want
you live in nice places you have all
this food and
why why could you possibly be depressed
because they don't they don't have a
purpose right and i think you know
andrew yang wants to send everyone
twelve thousand dollars a year it's like
is that i don't know people can just
like sit back and relax and play video
games all day and get a decent
you know apartment and have enough money
just
what thanks for checking out this clip
from the tim cast irl podcast
if you want to see the full show come
back to this channel youtube.com
tim cast irl monday through friday at 8
pm where you can leave comments
and super chat and we actually will read
your comments
on the show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want
exclusive members only content segments
you can't get anywhere else
go to timcast.com become a member and we
even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time